mission accomplie Flor a battu son
record de traversé de l'Atlantique en
solitaire et même si certains
reconnaissent pas une valeur de
v
aprsmi
[Applaudissements]
é bien les emades de mère vcueillir dans
le port de
Brest première femme à avoir traversé
l'Atlantique en moins de 10 jours
Florence a définitivement gagné le droit
d'entrer dans la famille des navigateurs
en solitaire Olivier de kerszon a tenu
lui aussi à la
félicité parti de New York sur son
trimaran Groupe Pierre prer le 24
juillet elle a effacé 7 nuits des
tablettes le temps réalisé en 87 par
Bruno Peron 9 jours 21h 42es un record
qui doit beaucoup aux conditions météo
et au conseil avisé de son routeur Louis
Baudin mais Florence refuse de
considérer sa performance comme quelque
chose
d'exceptionnel ça fait quand même pas
mal de temps maintenant que je que que
que je vis sur l'eau depuis 76 où j'ai
arrêté mes études de médecine je ne fais
que du bateau je ne fais que naviguer
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps donc je me considère
pas comme une femme qui fait du bateau
mais comme un marin cette cette
traversée d'Atlantique ce record
d'atlentique que je viens de faire est
pour moi une épreuve parmi beaucoup
d'autres une épreuve qui permet surtout
à la navigatrice de redorer son image de
marque et de rassurer son sponsor sur
ses possibilités prochain Paris pour
Florence toujours en solitaire la route
du Rome le 4 novembre prochain